So I was initially going to talk about buy and try specifics, but apparently someone else is going to talk about try specifics.
So that gave me extra two minutes. So, all right, we're good.
So let me just put it in context. Right. So Vinay said, you know, he showed you the history of this meeting.
Let's talk about the history of buy specifics. So we opened the first buy specific trial around 2019 at City of Hope.
And I think all of the people at this table open and can also say we had low expectations and they so surpassed our expectations in terms of having response rates of about 60 percent of people with a median of five prior lines of therapy.
So as a single agent, something we'd really never seen. So that was 2019.
Fast forward 2022 to, you know, 23 when these drugs got approved, we got to use them in more and more patients.
We started to understand the complexities.
Some of the complexities, why are patients relapsing?
This concept of antigen escape, which hopefully someone will speak to today.
Tumor heterogeneity, extramedullary disease, as well as some of the on target off tumor toxicities.
And how do we manage those better?
So now fast forward four years, 2026, where are we with buy specifics?
Well, hopefully we're getting a lot better at using them.
But as Tom already did a bunch of my slides, so thank you for that, Tom, in terms of early.
Clear lines of therapy and combinations.
That's really the future of our therapy.
So let's start with majestic seven front line settings.
So this is probably the real question there.
Can we do better in patients not intended for transplant beyond really what I would say has been our standard for many, many years of DRD?
So this was looking at both tech and TAL.
They did a safety run in and now we're in the main part of the trial.
Tech DR, TAL, DR, DRD.
So this trial is ongoing and we're waiting to see results.
I can tell you, I don't know if you guys have it open.
Everyone we've put on the buy specific arms, you know, has responded.
So, you know, of course, now we're thinking about toxicity, quality of life and PFS.
But again, I think this is going to be the future, certainly.
Now, let's move on to the next.
Here you can see right now, this was the safety run and already very impressive.
Ninety two percent.
Sixty percent of patients getting a stringent CR.
I mean, that's equivalent to what you can do with quad induction and a single transplant.
So pretty impressive.
Let's talk about tech five now.
So looking at this in the context of stem cell transplant.
So here again, you see tech.
I find this trial interesting because you give tech weekly, you give tech Q four weeks.
So understanding how do we play with these drugs to get less toxicity but maintain efficacy?
And Tom said life support.
This is one trial which sort of brings me to that question about life support for transplant, because look at after induction.
If you get 100 percent response rate, you have to ask yourself, what is the transplant adding on top of this in terms of 100 percent of patients getting not just response, but MRD negative?
So I think this, again, is also going to be very interesting to us as this trial evolves in terms of looking at durability of these responses.
Of course, we can't use any of these.
We can't use any of those yet.
That's still in the investigational phase.
What can we use?
So, of course, March of this year, tech DARA was approved.
And we have the CAR-T queen here.
So I'm not ready to say that CAR-T is on life support.
But let me point out tech three.
So the key parts of tech three, they excluded patients had prior BCMA therapy and they excluded patients.
Who were refractory to CD38.
And so and of course, that is because the control arm was DPD or DBD, about five percent of patients ended up having CD38 exposure.
So that for us really becomes the main question of this trial.
If you just look at the schedule, I do want to point out a couple of things.
The good thing, they mirrored the DARA schedule.
So eventually the tech also became monthly.
The not so good thing is this was still treat to disease progression.
And you remember Tom showed you cure.
Cure was off therapy.
So how do we put this into that context?
We're going to have to see.
But of course, my care is not as good at tech, Leal, but it's pretty darn good.
I mean, like in first relapse, these are the kind of patients that we would consider for CAR-T.
So, you know, I'm just saying, you know, off the shelf and easy regimen to give.
So something to think about now.
And of course, March 5th, this drug was a.
This combination was approved.
So I'm glad we don't have a debate.
It would be interesting to see which side people fall on.
The other thing I want to say is combination therapy.
Right. And I know you guys use this a lot at UCSF because we all share the same patients.
We do the same consults and we go back and forth.
And this is a combination that many of us are using.
We're using Taldarapam, we're using Tectarapam.
And you can see here from the TRIM2 data that you do get higher response rates.
So we tend to use these combinations.
And people who have much more refractory, difficult to treat disease, and of course,
it's not just with teclastamab, it's with Elra, it's with Linvo, everyone is sort of
doing this.
And you can see response rates do get higher, but up to the 80% range when you use these
combination therapies.
And then of course, GPRC, let's not forget that one, as Dr. Chari says, he loves all
his children equally.
So this is Talquetamab, the GPRC targeting drug.
Same idea.
Combination therapy, Taldara that Dr. Chari reported on, you can see response rate 70%
to 80%.
I actually found the Tal checkpoint inhibitor really interesting.
I wish that had moved forward because many of us think that it would actually be one
of the best partners to a bispecific.
Taltec, of course, a redirect study showed, especially in extramedullary disease, which
is the particularly hard to treat group for us, very high response rates, and then Talpalminab.
Another favorite combination.
So let me just talk about Taltec that Dr. Usmani presented at ASH combination trial and looking
truly at EMDs.
So in the myeloma world, EMD is controversial because you have to define it properly.
Is it paramedullary or is it extramedullary?
And this, we all think extramedullary disease is really the poor actor.
And you can see they look, they were very specific in this and they showed incredibly
high response rates.
And those response rates seem to be holding up.
And so here again, I think this is very promising data for us because even with CAR-T, as Dr.
Patel can tell you, this is a tough group of patients and I'm already running over.
So let me just finish bispecifics in 2026 are evolving.
We're moving them to earlier lines of therapy.
We're using combinations.
The future I think is really going to be giving them for fixed duration and certainly using
them in the frontline setting.
And the transplant question, I think I totally agree will become less and less something
we use frontline.
So thank you.